وتذهب الى بغداد مراسله صباح العربيه من
هناك زينب المشاط يسعد هالصباح يا زينب او
ولد
صباح الخير نادين انا شايفك طبعا انتهت
زمن الحروب اللي كانت اسلحتها
انتهى الزمن الحروب
تزين المتاحف والمنازل الفخمه وصارت هدايا
وتداول تتداول بين الملوك
والوجهاء والزعماء هذه يعني هذا شيء ممكن
يبرر بقاء المهنه الى يومنا هذا هذه
المهنه اللي ظهرت بالبدايه في الهند ودمشق
وبعدها انتشرت في كل بلدان العالم ايضا
كانت السيوف تصنع من ماده البرونز بعد ان
عرف الانسان الحديد
صار يصنعها من الحديد اا تطورت المهنه
كذلك وظهرت اجهزه ومعدات ومكائن لصناعه
السيوف لكن ميزه ضيفنا اليوم انه لا يزال
يصنع السيوف بالطريقه القديمه والجديئيه
صباح الخير حاج حيدر
نورتنا على صباح
ايه يعني من السنه الثامنه انت تصنع
السيوف لحد هذا اليوم هل هذا يعني انه
المهنه متوارثه من الاعضاء والاجداد
يعني عده اعمال بالصيغه اشتغلت بعدين
استقريت على مهنه السيوف التلمدت على يد
ستاد المرحوم عبود ومن خلال هذا العمليات
تعلمت هذه المهنه وطورتها
هل السيوف المصنعه بالطريقه القديمه افضل
من السيوف المصنعه بالمكائن وليش الناس
ترغب لها اكثر طبعا السيوف
اكثر وبيت تقنيه اعلى يعني ممكن همم سيف
يصنعوه بالفريز او ماده السي ان سي
الكتابات ولهذا بس مين يكون الشغل بالايد
يعني الصانع ياخذ راحته بال- ممكن يعطي
تسجيل للكلمه اللي ينقشها ممكن
تعطي هذا التسجيل لاحظ اكو انواع مختلفه
من السيوف مثل هذا الفيديو اكو سيوف اكبر
حجم واشكال مختلفه هل هذه الانواع لها
علاقه بهويه البلد يعني اللي صنعها الى
نوع سيف مثلا هذا السيف يصلح له سلاح روسي
من طراز القائم هذه استعينوا يستخدمون من
قبل شعوب القوقاز اكو سيوف مغوليه هذا
السلاح مغولي ايه مغولي الهندي استخدموه
اهلا سيف العربي كان مقاول السيف العربي
من زمن الجاهليه الى صدر الاسلام هو الشيخ
مستقيم ذو حد واحد او ذو حد يعني اسمه
دباب او راس نصف مدور وبعدين بدك تقويس من
داخل الحضارات التقويص البسيط يعتبر السيف
المهند او الهنداوي سيف الهند اليمن اكثر
تقويس سيوف الفارسيه لا يكون كل شيء مقوس
يصح ولا من طراز الشمس
ثقافي شخصيات فنيه يعني لحد اخر قبل شهرين
او اكثر اشتغلت اخر سيف للملك سلمان الملك
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه همم الشيخ مكتوم
الله يرحمه والله الشيخ زايد
محليا هوايه مشتغل من الرئيس السابق صدام
حسين مشتغل سيف او سيوف وقطع اسلاميه لحد
هاي اللحظه
مثلا
اصعب شغل صناعه الاسلحه وعندي سيف ذو
الفقار وراده بتقريبا متر و20 سم
عدد القبضه فهذا طولت به حوالي اربعه اشهر
اربعه اشهر وشويه
طيب الماده الاساسيه لصناعه السيوف
الماده الاساسيه لصناعه السيوف وشلون تبلش
شلون يعني تشوف شنطه تختار هذه الماده
الاساسيه
يعني مواد نستخدمها اللي هو الفولاذ
الحديد الفولاذ اللي هو جوهر هذا الجوهر
يعتبر خليط معادن وكربونات وهذا انا
نستخدم صناعه النصوله وبالاغمده نستخدم
الفضه او الذهب او التطعيم الفضل بالذهب
او الذهب بالغرام
يعني كنت حابه بس للاسف انتهى الوقت يا
زينب شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لضيفك ومن بغداد
مراسله صباح العربيه زينب المشاط شكرا لكم